c'est le mot le plus commenté en ce
moment dans le monde le coronavirus le
bilan s'alourdit d'heure en heure et
compterait aujourd'hui 170 morts selon
le gouvernement chinois qui annonce que
7700 personnes ont déjà été contaminées
et on l'a appris il ya quelques minutes
un sixième cas a été confirmé en france
mais ces dernières heures c'est un
bateau bloqué près de rome qui préoccupe
grandement les autorités un navire de
croisière avec à son bord six mille
passagers qui sont en quarantaine suite
à une alerte de coronavirus et visant un
couple de chinois se trouvant dans le
bateau une panique générale qui a poussé
dans l'urgence les compagnies msc et
costa à suspendre temporairement toutes
les croisières vers la chine de son côté
ces dernières heures air france a
également pris la décision de suspendre
tous ses vols vers la chine et ce vent
de panique qui souffle sur la planète
est alimenté ces derniers jours par de
nombreuses vidéos et informations qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux comme
cette vidéo d'un camion qui serait en
train de désinfecter en urgence la ville
de shanghai
d'autres informations sont encore plus
inquiétantes selon plusieurs articles
relayée sur twitter et facebook
les scientifiques auraient attester que
l'ensemble des 11 millions d'habitants
de maurane la ville d'où est originaire
le virus
allez tous décédés sans exception dans
les prochaines semaines une information
qui est évidemment fausse une autre
information fait état de 44 coronavirus
en région parisienne un chiffre que les
autorités françaises voudrait dissimulé
enfin selon d'autres sources le virus
aurait été créé de toutes pièces en
laboratoire par des équipes américaines
encore une fête news autour du
coronavirus mais alors faut-il paniquer
quelle est la véracité de ses
informations faut-il craindre le pire on
vous dit tout avec le docteur saldmann
alors le virus provoque un vent de
panique mondiale en pleine épidémie un
film sorti en 2011 a refait surface dans
le top 10 des téléchargements
il s'agit de contagion et oui c'est un
truc de fou le film qui raconte une
terrible pandémie mondiale qui n'épargne
personne
on appris aujourd'hui que 7000 personnes
sont bloquées sur un navire de croisière
en italie peuvent pas descendre à cause
d'un couple suspecté d'avoir le
coronavirus regarder ça aussi c'est fou
depuis ce matin un paquebot de la
compagnie costa croisières est bloqué
avec ses 7000 passagers à bord on voit
ces images de ce paquebot qui s'appelle
le costa esmeralda
il est en croisière mais à bord il ya un
couple de gens venus de macao
semble-t-il qui ont de la fièvre
du coup les 7000 passagers sont bloqués
à bord en attendant de savoir s'il
s'agit ou pas de ce virus
chinois ça c'est incroyable alors ce qui
se passe et je vous le dis il ya une
information qui vient de tomber
regardez puisque l' oms voilà annonce
qui c'est une urgence à refaire
nationale qui a été décrétée par le ms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
vous dire que c'est assez grave ce qui
se passe
le président voulait nous donner votre
avis docteur saldmann dans un instant le
président de la république a réagi ce
matin sur le coronavirus regard des
normes du gouvernement et des services
sanitaires sont mobilisés jeudi
remercier l'ensemble des personnels
soignants qui se sont mobilisés depuis
le début de cette crise comme l'ensemble
des des services de l'état et des
acteurs associatifs élus et acteurs
privés qui ont été mobilisés nous sommes
dans la vigilance la plus extrême
la mobilisation je le dis de l'ensemble
des services et une information continue
qui est donnée par la ministre de la
santé avec les services compétents qu'il
continuera de se faire alors docteur
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire là dessus
est ce qu'il faut craindre le pire ou
pas parce que là on entend une chose ça
vraiment ça évolue tous les jours il ya
encore un sixième cas je vous voilà qui
vient d'être annoncée sixième cas et
regardez on donne sa version vous allez
nous donner votre avis dans un instant a
regardé le sixième cas qui a l'air assez
sérieux
nous avons appris aujourd'hui un sixième
cas il s'agit d'un médecin libéral qui a
été contact d'un cas confirmé ensuite en
asie il s'est isolé rapidement lé
enquête épidémiologique sur les caps
contacts éventuels est en cours
aujourd'hui je voudrais signaler que
cette alerte a été donnée par la
confirmation d'un cas par un pays
asiatique et donc c'est pour montrer que
la communication entre l'asie et les
autorités sanitaires françaises est
excellente et donc il ya une
coordination internationale lorsqu'on
appelle de contact racing on s'appelle
entre pays pour signaler des cas et pour
signaler des cas contacts qui auraient
quitté le territoire
alors regardez le truc qui vient de
tomber à l'instant l'om est-ce décrète
l'urgence internationale fosso nouveau
coronavirus 1/6 quatre cours d'un virus
est confirmée en france
l'organisation mondiale de la santé gré
des crêpes l'urgence internationale
cette déclaration n'est pas dû à ce qui
se passe en chine mais ce qui se passe
dans les autres pays précise le
directeur général de l'om est ce là
est-ce qu'il faut prendre la place est à
prendre
extrêmement au sérieux la frédéric
saldmann
qu'est ce qui se passe en fait le corona
virus il n'y a pas de vaccin il n'y a
pas de traitement
on est face à une épidémie qui s'étend
et des gens qui meurent effectivement
lentement étouffés parce que vous avez
une asphyxie parce que les poumons sont
atteints
donc en fait c'est c'est quand même un
gros problème mais quand on regarde de
près les gens qui décèdent justement
c'est des gens qui sont pour la
l'immense majorité plus vulnérables au
niveau immunitaire au niveau de ces
virus
on aura encore dans les années à venir
d'autres pandémies de virus on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge
donc qu'est ce qui est important c'est
de penser à son statut immunitaire et
justement on en parlait tout à l'heure
le fait de faire de l'exercice physique
le jeune séquentielle dont on parlait
tout ce qu'on peut faire
l'hygiène qui est très importante tous
ces gestes du quotidien tels que plus
notre bouclier mais à fort plus notre
immunité est fort plus on passera au
travers de tout ça c'est début d'une
histoire et céder une bonne idée faut
toujours prendre revenir à quelque chose
de positif dans quelque chose
d'inquiétant comme ça il faut appeler le
mode de vie
l'hygiène va être vraiment fondamental
pour bien se protéger
gilles ce qui est inquiétant je trouve
c'est que l'om est prend une mesure
plusieurs jours après avoir dit que
finalement c'était pas la peine on a
l'impression que entre guillemets on
court après le virus est qu'à chaque
fois on découvre ce qui se passe qu'on
ne maîtrise rien c'est ça qui fait peur
donc il ya des faits cnous qui se refait
pas on sait que rien n'est maîtrisé ou
découvrir comme ça quant à virus démarre
il se propage comme la grippe ce virus
donc effectivement on sait pas ce que ça
va donner
parfois ça monte et ça descend quand on
voit l'épidémie de grippe ça monte ça
descend
et parfois ça descend pas voulait dire
que ça peut être saisonnier en fait
c'est ça ça pour la fois ça se tasse
tout seul on l'a vu dans les années va
mais là ça prend c'est pas revoir ça
c'est en voyant michel fait peur c'est
qu'on n'y a pas de traitement mais
j'imagine que les chercheurs le travail
est ce qu'on peut espérer qu'il ya un
vaccin rapidement pour la cible soit lié
à mon avis ça arrivera trop tard le
temps de la balle ovale combien de temps
il faut pour un motard trop tard je les
cieux aujourd'hui pour trouver un vaccin
on peut le temps que sa mère on
n'arrivera pas atteint
oui valérie ce qui est ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que là en l'occurrence
le sixième cas c'est effectivement un
médecin qu'il a eu les bons réflexes
immédiatement sur le sol français a été
soi seul français immédiatement il s'est
isolé mais une personne lambda mme vous
moi le premier truc qu'on fait le
crachat les arabes les symptômes
ressemblent à la glisse c'est dire que
s'ils avaient vraiment les symptômes
francs tout de suite on saigne en fait
ces bâtards les gens sont à une bulle
hier ils sont pas bien et en fait c'est
ça mais ça peut être une bonne moi je
pensais dans les deux mois là on va tous
types et moi je rejoins valérie la saa
médecins en bonne santé en pleine forme
qu'il a eu les bons réflexes exactement
là vous vous dites c'est les personnes
qui sont celles de la jeunesse est un
mec cac 40 balais il tombe comme un
virus
moi je suis chez moi c'est celle là on
va vraiment en paix c'est ça et parce
que le maintien voilà avec ça ils
avaient tombola est il en bonne santé il
a eu quand même - parme il l'a vu mais
il a de très très fort de chances de
s'en sortir
malheureusement oui les gens le attrape
ce virus mais la majorité s'en sorte
d'accord ma que non le paradoxe docteur
c'est que on dit voilà tous voient cyril
qui se laver les mains on fait attention
on fait attention
or on se rend compte que justement c'est
en faisant pas trop attention que
finalement on peut avoir des saloperies
qui créent les anticorps et qui nous
rendent plus fort donc finalement à
cause aussi la médecine et de tout ce
que vous nous avez amené en
antibiotiques dans tout ça aujourd'hui
on est aussi on est fragilisé très
vulnérable et là vous continuez à dire
lavez vous les mains tout ça c'est pas
le paradoxe dire que le mot et on a
remarqué par exemple que les gens qui
dorment insuffisamment attaque beaucoup
plus souvent la grippe donc le statut
l'énergie vitale que vous avez votre
santé c'est votre bouclier l'exercice
physique c'est formidable ça monte les
défenses immunitaires
donc en fait pour les gens qui passent
au travers de cette infection il y en
aura d'autres dans les années à venir
c'est on est de plus en plus nombreux
les hommes c'est comme les poulets plus
on est nombreux
les risques de pandémie sont importants
au caveau ni dormir et faire de
l'exercice et ya rien de mieux à faire
pour ne pas choper le truc là pas
seulement également l'alimentation est
très importante aussi
merci un peu bas sur les gens qui sont
ré qui font attention à leur hygiène de
vie et un bouclier pour passer au
travers beaucoup plus puissant ce que
vous mettez les enfants les personnes
vulnérables dans les enfants globalement
parfois peut-être
aussi un cas dans une école mais
globalement ils s'en sortent bien
d'accord isabelle et c'est vrai que
l''indice de précaution en france elle
joue en une semaine il ya un cas concret
là est un des médecins des chefs de top
chef qui vient de chine à shanghai
il est arrivé dimanche dernier il a eu
aucun contrôle l'aveyron à l'aéroport
son directeur arrive là des qui va
arriver à paris il est choqué et il a il
est en confinement immédiatement sauf
donc ce cas en une semaine la situation
et l'attitude a changé sauf que cette
mesure là de prendre la température par
exemple pour tous les purées de chine
etc
c'est une mesure hautement politique
pour simplement dire on fait quelque
chose mais en fait ce fait c'est une
place soir parce que de toute façon tu
peux ne pas avoir de fièvre et avoir un
cube et le biais de semaine à 8 jours
est arrivée sur le territoire
donc c'est juste simplement pour
rassurer la population l'avion bah oui
alors c'est vrai que là ça fait
extrêmement flipper voilà ce qu'on voit
on va voir ce que vous en pensez vous
faut-il craindre le pire
oui à 51% non à 49 a quand même puis
voilà 51% sur le pire c'est qu'on nous
ment que nous a toujours menti quand ses
concurrents les vétérans les ministres
et tout ça on sait on nous a menti
affirme bill quand vous regardez la
série en promouvant surtout sur le
binôme nuage est passé à sa delà de
l'absence à ce qui se passe en chine
mais en france on vous dit la vérité
les autorités font leurs yeux disent la
vérité en france oui on dit la vérité
oui parce que on peut absolument pas
qu'elles n'ont pas peur d'un vent de
panique et ils disent n'aura pas permis
dans les jambes cassées que c'est pas
parce qu'on la trappe ce coronavirus
qu'on va mourir
fort heureusement la major que moi celle
du dr naman giuly j'ai entendu des gens
dire voilà mine de rien ce qui prime
mais on le sait ça qu'est pousser
l'économie
bien sûr ils disent les gens si on
commence à les faire paniquer ils vont
plus sortir de chez eux
l'économie va être touchée et commerces
moi de toucher donc forcément ça va voir
bien sûr un impact très fort sur
l'économie donc est ce qu on part on
fait pas le ferait pas mieux de
minimiser en fait qui se passe au
pouvoir le sauver
soyez à sauver cyril regarde l incendie
que ya pas très longtemps pardon je sais
plus dans quelle ville qui était
chimiques ou un amant il ya tous les
gens qui étaient dedans à rouen pardon
alors a dit qu'il ait pas de risque
patrice pas de risques et on s'est rendu
compte qu'il ne pouvait pas respirer
qu'il ya un énorme risque chimique le
maire a menti vrai ou faux
voir le mal partout on voit pas le mal
on voit pas le mal mais c'est pas
ça a changé quand même mais c'est moche
alors peut-être que ça a changé parce
qu'il découvre des choses
voilà mais vous pensez que vous il n'ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de voie la norme
parce que quelque part on a chaque année
déjà la grippe aussi way it eu aussi
mais tout le monde nous parle de la
grippe mais mine de rien quand on est
les rues avec grippe on est on est on
est pas alors on est parti à les uns la
canton millions d'alcoron d'un virus je
pense que tous les gens qu'on connaît
pas on a peur parce que tout le monde
nous dit il ya des gens qui meurent de
la grippe aussi oui oui mille fois oui
moi je trouve que ça same way c'est un
mauvais argument n'a jamais bloqué un
bateau de 7000 personnes pour une
récemment regardez regardez ce thé dans
le jt de tf1 garde depuis ce matin un
paquebot de la compagnie costa
croisières est bloqué avec ses 7000
passagers à bord on voit cette image de
ce paquebot qui s'appelle le costa
esmeralda
il est en croisière mais à bord il ya un
couple de gens venus de macao
semble-t-il qui ont de la fièvre
du coup les 7000 passagers sont bloqués
à bord en attendant de savoir s'il
s'agit ou pas de ce virus chinois alors
voilà je voulais montrer de talent mais
c'est vrai que voilà ça commence wyatt
et les trucs qu'on voyait pas il ya une
semaine en son nom très sincèrement on
sait pas comment ça va évoluer
ça peut se passer comme s'amplifier au
nez aux états d'où on connaît pas la
suite
gilles ce qui est fou sur l'image du
bateau vous avez raison de montrer c'est
que c'est un lieu clos mais hélas on ne
dit à deux personnes atteintes ont
bouclé tout mais quand ce sont des lieux
ouverts des gens dans les aéroports des
gens dans les villes on peut pas bouclé
donc on se dit là on peut boucler mais
sinon il ya des gens qui se baladent
avec ça qu'ils le transmettent et sepa
trouve que ça ça fait super peur moi
c'est terrifiant d'accord alors fait
l'examen qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous donner comme
conseils aux personnes qui nous
regardent qui commence à flipper voilà
moi je me dis voilà là je vais plus
serré les mains j'ai pu je peux agir
convaincu voilà deux personnes
c'est vrai qu'on se dit tous on va
rester chez nous ce week-end on va pas
sortir on commence à un peu à un flipper
un benhaim suis sûr que voilà déjà
qu'elle a mal au dos si jeu pour voir ce
à quoi vont d'un virus non mais c'est
quoi les conseils à donner il faut vivre
normalement où il faut se dire on
commence à prendre des mesures
on vit normalement tout simplement parce
qu'on n'est pas c'est pas un virus qui
tue tout le monde fort heureusement
quand on regarde les gens contaminés
l'immense majorité arabe ce virus et
guérissent donc quand même qu'en même
temps on guérit au plus pressé haut ça
peut durer
oui dix jours qu'un accord ça dépend des
accords tous les cas qu'on a vu après la
plainte la voilà la plupart des cas ne
guérissent la plupart des cas guérissent
casser l'élan de santé etc les gens
justement qu'une immunité vulnérables
qui sont vulnérables dans cette histoire
c'est pour ça que ça incite avoir une
bonne hygiène de vie
parce qu'on aura encore des épidémies
comme ça et tout ce que tous les atouts
qu'on met au quotidien fait qu'on se
défend mieux on a une armure par rapport
à tout ça battue je joue vraiment la
mission vous écoutez une mauvaise grippe
qui dure huit jours enfin il n'empêche
que c'est une grippe qui tuent beaucoup
et c'est une grippe qui fait que si hier
deux cas sur un bateau plus personne ne
sort on les met en quarantaine et là
encore vous avez un discours rassurant
parce que si vous dit quelque chose de
pas rassurant vous serez repris demain
partout avec dante et pmp docteur met en
garde de ne plus normalement
mais par définition oui docteur qu'on en
meure oui c'est très dangereux et non
c'est pas une grippe normale
alors oui j'y mets moi je vais vous dire
franchement donc nord et coronavirus et
un nom bizarre mais j'ai l'impression
dans ma tête je me disais qu'on a
l'impression de revivre les grandes
épidémies d'avant qui terrifiait je le
colle a fait baver
on se dit mais on va est ravagée par la
grippe espagnole des trucs comme ça qui
moi je commence vraiment à flipper je
vous le dis franchement ont flippé
autour de la table valérie vidal hymne
puisque l'info vient de tomber l'aller
les deux personnes sur le bateau et elle
n'avait pas le coronavirus donc
finalement le bateau la quarantaine tous
se sont alors